le combat continue une nouvelle fois en
musique pour le solidays le festival est
reconduit du 23 au 25 juin pour une 19e
édition sur l'hippodrome de longchamp à
paris
objectif récolter des fonds pour lutter
contre le sida
cette année 80 concerts sont programmés
sur cette scène j'ai le sentiment que
pour cette dixième édition solidays à
une programmation toujours aussi riche
et varié elle se veut éclectique puisque
on est là pour voir donner envie à tout
le monde se veut multi générationnel
parce qu on est là pour les jeunes et
les moins jeunes l'ambiance solidaire
c'est une ambiance rock hip hop
familiale chanson française décalée
kitsch c'est de l'information
c'est comme on appelle ça de l'émotion
le festival jongleurs encore cette année
entre les artistes inconnus du grand
public et les têtes d'affiché parmi les
nouveautés les festivaliers pourront
voir en action le groupe de rock
malgache 10 ibrahim
parmi les chanteurs confirmés l'artiste
féfé participera ce rendez vous tout le
monde veut faire solidays en général
c'est un roman un festival espace et
unique autant pour la cause qui est
apprécié jean c'est très agréable parce
que public est hyper chaleureux
au programme également des expositions
des tables rondes et des conférences sur
le sida la sexualité des thèmes
importants pour la région ile-de-france
qui n'hésitent pas à verser huit cent
mille euros dans le festival environ 4
euros par festival des parce que le sida
n'a pas disparu parce que 40 % des
séropositifs de france sont en ile de
france parce que l'île de france est
aussi le lieu de la fête
et je crois que c'est important pour
continuer à véhiculer ses messages de
prévention
vis-à-vis de tous les jeunes et ça c'est
le rôle de son décès pour ça que la
région est aussi mobilisée après une
fréquentation record plus de 200 mille
festivaliers en 2016 l'événement la
fiche toujours pas complet pourrait voir
une baisse cette année selon les
organisateurs nouvelle qui n'enlève pas
l' enthousiasme des artistes tous
j'aurais craché